[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar beyond infection prevention and
control how genome sequencing of amr
pathogens can improve antibiotic
stewardship and patient care
i am kayleigh lock of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by opt-gen
to learn more visit optigen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
arna materna ceo of aeris genetics and
opt-gen group company dr materna you may
now begin your presentation
hello everybody and welcome to this
latest installment of our webinar series
on antimicrobial resistance my name is
arne martinez i am the ceo of aries
genetics
and over the course of the webinar we
will explore the positive impact that
whole genome sequencing can have
on antibiotic stewardship in general and
on patient care and healthcare economics
in particular
as always first a few words about
aristogenetics
during previous webinars we have already
explored the root causes for
antimicrobial resistance the need for
antibiotic stewardship to counter the
spread of amr and the positive effect
that pathogen genome sequencing and
surveillance can have on antibiotic
stewardship efforts
with the eggmed event just behind us we
will start today with an update on the
latest numbers quantifying the global
burden of amr
after briefly revisiting the benefits of
genomic surveillance and pathogen hold
genome sequencing uh here abbreviated
with wgs
we will dive into recent advances in
accuracy and turnaround time of whole
genome sequencing and the use of machine
learning for the prediction of
antibiotic treatment response directly
from bacterial genome data
i will conclude the seminar by reviewing
studies that explore the clinical
utility of whole genome sequencing
and present data on healthcare economic
and patient benefits
let's begin with an update on the global
burden of amr
a study dubbed the gram study ground
thereby standing for the global research
on antimicrobial resistance project has
found much attention
the study was published in the lancet
this year and it is offering a
comprehensive analysis of the global
burden of amr it shows that a staggering
4.95 million deaths
in 2019 alone were associated with
bacterial amr
associated with thereby means that if
all drug resistant infections were
replaced by no infection then 4.95
million deaths could have been prevented
in 2019
this number has put bacterial amr on
place three of the leading underlying
causes of death only behind ischemia
heart disease and stroke
a more conservative 1.27 million deaths
were directly attributable to amr
directly attributable thereby meaning
that if all drug resistant infections
were replaced by drug susceptible
infections
then 1.27 million deaths could have been
prevented in 2019
in other words
1.27 million deaths were caused by the
effect of amr on infectious diseases
if we compare this number to the seven
hundred thousand deaths due to amr in
2014
um this number is an estimate in the
o'neill report published in 2015
then the fatalities due to amr have
grown by more than 81 percent in only 5
years
these numbers emphasize the pandemic
nature of amr which only underscores the
importance of urgent and globally
coordinated action
the gram study further revealed that the
amr all age death rates are highest in
low to mid-income countries in
sub-saharan africa
south asia eastern europe and south
latin america
this makes mr not only a major global
health problem but a particularly
serious problem for some of the poorest
countries in the world
as you can see in this chart
all six of the leading pathogens
contributing to the burden of amr in
2019 matched the ones previously
identified as priority pathogens by the
who
they include in this order escherichia
coli staphylococcus aureus klebsiella
pneumoniae streptococcus pneumoniae
acinetobacter barmanii and pseudomonas
aeruginosa
in the high income super region
approximately half of the fatal amr
burden was actually linked to the two
pathogens staff warriors with 26.1
percent of death attributable to amr
and e coli with 23.4 percent of death
attributable to amr
by contrast in sub-saharan africa and
other low-income regions the leading
pathogens were distinct from those of
the high-income super region
and each represented a smaller share of
the mr burden complicating the issue in
those countries
the leading types of infections
contributing to the amr burden globally
include lower respiratory tract
infections bloodstream infections
intra-abdominal infections urinary tract
infections and tb
this figure explores the antibiotic
treatment options that were critically
impacted in their efficacy by amr
the analysis showed that resistance to
fluoroquinolones and beta-lactam
antibiotics accounted for more than 70
percent of deaths attributable to amr
across pathogens
beta-lactam antibiotics thereby include
carbopenum cephalosporins including
third and fourth generation
cephalosporins and penicillins
critically thereby is that the these
affected antibiotics are often used as a
first line for empirical therapy of
severe infections
in 2017 the who published a priority
list of pathogens to guide the
development of new and effective
antibiotic treatments
interestingly only five of the seven top
pathogen drug combinations that the
ground study estimated have caused the
most deaths in 2019
are currently on this who priority list
for instance fluoroquinolone resistant e
coli are not included and medicine
resistant staph warriors while the
pathogen drug combination causing most
deaths in 2019
is listed as having a high but not a
critical priority
findings like the ones presented by the
authors of the gram study clearly show
that surveillance data are crucial to
inform policies
given the rapid growth of amr and that
we review data from 2019 in 2022 shows
that there is an urgent need for more
continuous and globally integrated
surveillance
the authors of the gram study therefore
concluded with a set of noteworthy key
insights
first and foremost the world is simply
not doing enough to address amr our
current action plans are not ambitious
or fast enough to control the threat
these estimates are a warning signal
common infections have already become
harder to treat putting extra pressure
on frontline healthcare workers
immediate actions are required to help
countries around the world protect their
health systems against the threat of amr
the als the authors also make policy
recommendations for instance on
surveillance
they urge greater action to monitor and
control infections globally nationally
and also within individual hospitals
this requires accelerated support for
infection prevention and control
as well as for antibiotic stewardship
measures to reduce the use and overuse
of antibiotics
especially antibiotic use unrelated to
treating
treating human disease has to be reduced
but also antimicrobial treatment of
infections has to expand access to
life-saving antibiotics were needed and
effective while minimizing use where
they are not effective or necessary
the use of effective antibiotics while
avoiding overuse of ineffective or
unnecessary ones is in a nutshell the
definition of antibiotic stewardship
the question of course is how to
identify treatment options that will not
be met with resistance in a given
outbreak or a patient
the who in its global action plan on amr
emphasizes again that the optimal
antibiotic use reduces the spread of amr
and improves patient outcomes
the action plan proposes to improve
antibiotic stewardship by focusing on
technical solutions that support on one
hand the rapid diagnosis of resistance
as such diagnostics can help inform a
more targeted antimicrobial therapy
on the other hand the majority of
antibiotics are still empirically
prescribed informed based on
surveillance data
therefore solutions for surveillance are
needed that not only track the emergence
and transmission of pathogen outbreaks
but also of the pathogens ability to
meet different antibiotic treatments
with resistance
let's take a look at the technologies
that are in the clinic today
the standard of care in infectious
disease diagnosis are bacterial cultures
which are routinely used for the
identification of infective agents and
the determination of suitable antibiotic
treatment options
when a culture comes back positive
meaning pathogen growth is present then
antibiotic susceptibility testing also
referred to as ast is performed to
determine which antibiotics are
effective and which will likely be met
with resistance
while these culture-based methods in asd
are being considered the gold standard
they are often labor intensive and may
miss difficult to culture pathogens
also turnaround times range from one to
three days or even more which is long
considering that patients with acute
infections require urgent care within
hours
this lack of sensitivity and speed is
addressed by modern molecular tests
relying on pcr
leading pcr panels such as the tests
available on the curator's universe
system achieve very high sensitivities
and can return results in a matter of
hours even pushing the limit below one
hour
these powerful systems can screen for up
to a few hundred biomarkers in a single
test enabling them to simultaneously
screen for pathogen and amr markers
at option and at ares genetics we aim to
complement such rapid molecular tests
with sequencing technology
given that today the number of known
genetic markers for amr is measured in
the thousands
sequencing technologies hold the promise
to simultaneously and comprehensively
screen for any pathogen and all known
genetic markers for antibiotic
resistance while at the same time
delivering highly resolved information
on outbreaks and on transmission
patterns
delivering on this promise has firmly
emerged as a focus for aeris genetics
our goal is to develop sequencing assays
in bioinformatics that identify
pathogens in amar markers
that offer genotype and outbreak cluster
information
while also emulating the advantages of
culture by predicting whether detected
pathogens are susceptible or assisted to
antibiotic therapy
pathogen whole genome sequencing or here
again abbreviated with wgs
is increasingly adopted by clinical labs
and its utility for microbial typing and
epidemiology is already undisputed
it is the first technology that thanks
to an enormous sampling depth is not
only very sensitive but also captures
the entire genome allowing for an
exhaustive characterization of genetic
amr markers in a single test
and as i mentioned comprehensive genomic
information generated by wgs provides us
a chance to use artificial intelligence
and predictive modelling to emulate
culture-based ast and predict which
antibiotics represent suitable treatment
options
with sequencing costs and turnaround
times rapidly decreasing the opportunity
for complementing molecular testing
thereby revolutionizing the standard of
care in clinical microbiology is now no
longer out of reach
the need for whole genome sequencing is
in fact pervasive
in january july and again october 21 the
international health regulations
emergency committee for covit 19 has
recommended to increase global
sequencing capacities the ihr encouraged
the rapid sharing of data including
metadata and has asked the who to
actively support countries to strengthen
their systemic systematic genomic
surveillance
between march 21 and january 22
there was in fact a fourteen percent
increase in the proportion of who member
states with sequencing capability for
sars gov ii it was deployed in over
two-thirds of the member states in total
this is good news but it means that
there is now the need to sustain the
gains made and strengthen wgs capacities
further
in response the
wjwho has just published a 10-year
strategy for genomic surveillance the
goals of the strategy are to strengthen
genomic surveillance for pathogens with
pandemic and epidemic potential
including for amr pathogens
and to scale
genomic surveillance for quality and for
timely and appropriate public health
actions within local to global
surveillance systems
now let's revisit how wgs can assist us
in the fight against amr
here a quote by louisa gordon david
patterson patrick harris and co-workers
the authors of a study that we'll take a
closer look at in a minute
the authors state that
when compared to the standard of care
whole genome sequencing can
confirm or refute suspected related
cases in infectious pathogens in other
words it can detect outbreak clusters
and provide an early warning
it can discriminate between different
strains
which in other words allows for better
patient management by the infection
prevention and control teams and finally
whole genome sequencing can classify
novel pathogens
improving which which in turn improves
the diagnostic yield potentially leading
to more detected and appropriately
treated infections
given the potential value inherent to
whole genome sequencing the question is
how can we speed up its adoption
especially given that the workflows for
sample processing and data analysis
can be quite complex and sometimes
laborious
clinicians tell us that the answer to
this question has multiple facets for
one it is important to demonstrate
sufficient diagnostic performance of wgs
yet in addition to being accurate and
reproducible a broader adoption of whole
genome sequencing will also require an
understanding of its clinical utility
in other words its proven capacity for
improving patient outcomes while ideally
reducing the total cost of care
over the following slides we will
therefore exp explore both aspects of
of the clinical utility of whole genome
sequencing and we'll start with taking a
look at its diagnostic performance
to ensure the accurate performance of
our platform for isolated sequencing at
aries which we have dubbed aries iss
um and which we have made available as a
service last year we routinely validate
our workflows and publish the results
along with validation protocols
here the example of a study we've
published in 2020 in which the team has
validated rsiss
and the data analysis following clear
guidelines clia is a u.s standard for
laboratory developed tests
the performance was assessed using a
well-characterized using
well-characterized reference materials
and a number of parameters including
accuracy re
repeatability and reproducibility as
well as sensitivity and specificity were
recorded
the study showed that the iris process
for isolate sequencing
100 accurately and reproducibly
identified and genotype pathogens
also amor marker detection was highly
accurate with sensitivities and
specificities exceeding 95 and 99
respectively
with nanopore sequencing becoming
increasingly available
we have decided to conduct a second
multi-center validation of the workflow
for isolate sequencing rsiss this time
using the ont platform
nanopore sequencing is an interesting
platform for clinical microbiology for a
number of reasons
the turnaround time is very low
theoretically enabling same-day
reporting and workflows as short as 6
hours
the technology also generates long reads
which offer interesting advantages for
the assembly of bacterial genomes and
for example for the recovery of plasmids
finally the small footprint and the low
capital equipment cost as well as per
base cost make this an interesting
platform for clinical or surveillance
applications also in low to mid-income
countries
nanopore sequencing works by
translocating a single dna strand across
a biological pore and a membrane a
steady flow of ions through that pore
creates a current which can be measured
and which fluctuates in a dna sequence
specific pattern as the dna is
translocated through the pore
the downside is that both the nanopore
itself as well as the dna translocating
effect rely on life biological proteins
which introduce biological variability
into the system leading to a in theory
less accurate base calling compared to
for example illumina short
read sequencing
for our study the well characterized set
of reference materials was subjected to
dna dna extraction by different vendors
and the resulting dna extracts were
aliquoted and sent
to oxford nanopore technology
enabled partner labs for library
preparation and sequencing using the
10.4 flow cells and the rapid library
prep chemistry by ont
the results of this study have been
summarized in a white paper which you
can find on our website a manuscript
manuscript with a full assessment of the
diagnostic performance of our workflow
and our bioinformatics in the hands of
researchers at johns hopkins hospital
has been submitted
indeed the base calling quality was
reduced we obtain quality or q score on
the fret scale of about 11 to 12
compared to much higher q scores of 30
that we typically see with illumina data
however the assembly process resolves
some of the
associated problems after the novel
genome assembly we assess the average
nucleotide identity of assembled genomes
with a known public reference and
determined that the error rate was only
three to four fold higher compared to
illumina based assemblies
despite this unresolved difference in
sequencing error rate the aries
bioinformatics pipeline for whole genome
sequences on
for whole genome sequencing on the ont
platform performed well
the accuracy and reproducibility for
pathogen identification was hundred
percent
we also obtained high accuracies for aml
marker profiling and plasma detection
which were only slightly below the
performance of illumina data
most satisfying was the fact that the
antibiogram prediction direct directly
from genomic data using our predictive
antibiotic susceptibility testing
pipeline performed very well with an
accuracy of up to 97 percent and in line
with illumina data
the only area where the nanopore
technology needs to improve further is
bacterial typing using core genome mlst
as the involved bioinformatics are more
sensitive to sequencing error
we have enrolled with ont in the so
called q20 program um
sorry the q20 chemistry early access
program which is promising drastic
quality increases the first test runs
using the new chemistry also for core
genome memoricity typing
look promising but further testing is
required at this point
we've now established that the
diagnostic performance of wgs is high
offering results that are both accurate
and reducible
in order to maximize the impact of a
technology on amr outbreaks however we
established that a useful diagnostic has
to deliver insights into antibiotic
susceptibility and resistance for a
given outbreak or for an individual case
i will therefore review over the next
couple of slides
a machine learning assistive process
that we at aries genetics refer to as
predictive susceptibility testing or
pasd
which is the prediction of antibiograms
directly from genomic
to achieve antibiogram prediction we use
artificial intelligence which is trained
on data we continuously aggregated in a
proprietary database we call rsdb
rsdb holds to the best of our knowledge
a leading collection of genome and
associated phenotypic resistance data
from clinical isolates
currently the models to predict
antibiotics susceptibility
are trained as stacked ensemble models
which associate phenotypic ast results
with a variety of different genetic
markers including k-mers or gene or
protein annotations
this model-based approach can be
complemented by a rule-based approach
but it can other than purely rule-based
methods
take into account the synergistic or
antagonistic interaction of multiple amr
genes or mr-associated mutations and the
interplay between multiple antibiotic
compounds
as the figure in the middle illustrates
we not only rely on the presence or
absence of certain resistance genes but
we also consider changes in non-coding
regions of the genome as well as novel
markers that our predictive algorithms
have discovered
we demonstrated in several studies the
high categorical agreement between
standard of care results with the
resistance phenotypes we predicted based
on wgs data
these studies include for instance the
first multi-center evaluation
successfully demonstrating the
feasibility and performance of
predictive asd for 13 pathogens causing
lower respiratory tract infection
some of the study results are shown here
allow me to walk you through the
somewhat data dense slide the matrix on
the right hand side shows along the
horizontal axis the samples for the
various pathogens reported by the
standard of care
the vertical axis lists the different
antibody compounds by compound by
compound class that were tested for
each intersection in this matrix
represents a pathogen drug combination
and requires a separate predictive model
to be trained
the numbers for each of these
intersections or the fields in this
table
show the categorical agreement in
percent between predictive asd and
culture
if you exclude all pathogen drug
combinations for which pathogens are
intrinsically resistant
highlighted here in blue and those
combinations for which the standard of
care method did not detect any
resistance highlighted in gray then the
remaining white fields
of the table are the areas in which a
direct comparison of aeris predictive
asd
and
culture based ast is possible
as the green fields indicate we were
able to demonstrate high concordance
reaching for most of the pathogen drug
combinations values significantly above
the regulatory threshold for asd devices
of greater than 90
often achieving up to 100 percent
studies like this are not only important
for clinical validation purposes
we also embrace them as they give our
data science teams clear indicators on
which pathogen drug combinations to
focus our efforts on for predictive
model development and for database
curation
this slide shows the results of such an
effort to improve model performance for
a given drug bug combination through
focused biocuration and model training
together with our partners which include
for instance reference labs
we generate and aggregate isolate
genomes and the corresponding phenotypic
data on amr
the data show that by selectively
increasing the number of days of data
sets from isolates with specific
phenotypes we can systematically improve
categorical agreement as well as errors
shown here by the decrease of the
so-called very major error rate which is
the false susceptible rate
in summary biocuration and model
training go hand in hand and can improve
model performance for each bug drug
combination to levels in line with iv
device regulation
the benefit for our partner thereby
resides in being able to accurately
predict treatment response directly from
genomic surveillance data and of course
in having access to an up to an
up-to-date amount marker database
this slide intends to show the impact
that biocuration has on average
on the performance of our predictive ast
models
the figure on the right shows percent
categorical agreement between prediction
and the standard of care at the top
and the error rates for very major error
major error and minor errors at the
bottom
on the very right you can see the
average performance over all predictive
ast models we validated in the or we
evaluated in the original multi-center
study
again these values are averages also
including models which in our 2020 study
have underperformed due to insufficient
training data sets in the ares database
those models correspond to the white
fields in the matrix i just showed
the middle of the chart on this slide
shows the results of three independent
studies performed using our 2020
predictive models on different subsets
of the full spectrum of spectrum of drug
bug combinations
finally on the right hand side
highlighted in green you can see the
average performance across our
predictive ast models when trained based
on a more recent version of the rsdb
categorical agreement is very high with
an average 96 percent and also very
major errors and major error rates have
significantly improved
to ensure that predictive um that
predicting resistance and susceptibility
is not only accurate but also accessible
to researchers and clinicians without
expertise in bioinformatics or ai
we have launched last year eris cloud a
user-friendly web application which
fully automates predictive asd in other
words the antibiogram prediction
directly from genomic data
the platform generates reports which in
addition to antibiograms also include
information on sequence quality and
contamination of course on pathogen
identity and core genome embolicity
genotype to round out the solution we
have enabled users to drill into rich
information on individually detected amr
markers their prevalence and their
prognostic performance
also included is information on plasmids
and virulence factors
all reports some examples of which are
shown on this slide can be explored
online or exported with a click of a
button
for convenience aries cloud also
includes a set of comparative analysis
tools for the investigation of local
bacterial outbreaks
in summary we have now established that
whole genome sequencing offers accurate
and reproducible information on pathogen
identity genotype and outbreak
clustering
wgs offers insight into virulence and
amr revealing genetic markers mobile
elements and plasmids
wgs data in conjunction with artificial
intelligence can be used to accurately
detect amr and predict susceptibility
thereby offering a route to improve
treatment guidance and antibiotic
stewardship
the new long read platforms are becoming
a viable option for enabling same-day
reporting and
to lower capital equipment cost which
makes whole genome sequencing
increasingly suitable for the clinical
for the clinic and for surveillance in
low-to-mid income countries
and finally we have shown that
bioinformatics can be fully automated
and delivered through secure and
user-friendly applications
but not only has there been tremendous
progress on the site of diagnostic
performance also the question about the
clinical utility of whole genome
sequencing is being answered
as a quick reminder clinical utility is
defined as patient outcome divided by
the total cost of care
this means
to fully describe the utility of any new
intervention
its impact on both outcome and cost has
to be understood
and a number of researchers have focused
their efforts on furthering our
understanding of the clinical utility of
wgs
among the early adopters of clinical
whole genome sequencing were the german
team of alexander mellman doug harmson
and co-workers
in a 2016 study this team assessed the
overall sequencing costs using a case
during which 550 isolates were obtained
next they calculated the additional
direct healthcare costs plus the
indirect costs resulting from blocked
bets in the intensive care unit
associated with cases that could have
been prevented with whole genome
sequencing
interestingly the direct and indirect
health care costs were thereby very
conservatively assessed the team used
cost data that at the time of
publication were outdated by 15 years i
guess we can intuitively agree that
within 15 years costs for most things
have gone up while however the costs for
sequencing
in recent years have come down
despite this conservative approach the
team calculated for this specific case
involving again 550 isolates a total
cost saving
of
205 000 euros
as a positive side effect the team also
counted the avoided risks and
detrimental health impact associated
with patient patient isolation in an
intensive care unit
more recent studies use statistical
statistical mathematical modeling to
estimate the cost effectiveness of
routine whole genome sequencing as an
infection control tool
the studies by diamond and co-workers
and elliot and co-workers modeled the
effects of whole genome sequencing on
patient outcome and on healthcare cost
based on data they acquired from amr
breaks with mrsa and
oxa-181 e coli respectively
diamond and co-workers based their model
on data generated during a 12-month
prospective observational cohort study
they concluded that routine mri
sequencing would result in fewer cases
they included both colonization and
clinical infections
and to have a small but measurable
positive impact on health related
quality of life on a per patient basis
and that was that effect was regardless
of whether they
these patients
have been infected or were only tested
for mrsa
the team also estimated that routine
whole genome sequencing was likely to be
cost saving under the model assumptions
the team including elliot and co-workers
conducted a model simulation of the
clinical utility of whole genome
sequencing during an active outbreak in
a hospital
their model was motivated by and trained
on data from an oxa 181 e coli outbreak
in april of 2017
the findings of the simulation reveal
that whole genome sequencing of a
potentially serious pathogen appears
effective in containing an outbreak and
minimizing hospital costs at the same
time they predicted that without the use
of whole genome sequencing the number of
colonized patients would increase by
78.7 percent
and the associated costs would increase
by almost 70 67
finally i'd like to highlight a study
from 2021 conducted by louisa gordon
david patterson patrick harris and
co-workers this is the team i quoted
earlier
motivated by the earlier promising
findings on the benefits of clinical
whole genome sequencing this team
decided to determine the effect on cost
and patient outcome but at a regional
level
they collected data from 27 hospitals
and considered the entire state of
queensland which is the second largest
and the third most populous in australia
for their analysis
the costs were modeled based on costs
for hospitalization sequencing and
epidemiology
the assumptions on amr incidents
considered annual hospitalizations which
are 410 000 hospitalizations in this
case
the point prevalence for
healthcare-associated infections in
australia which is 9.9
and the multi-drug resistance rates and
their trends
the costs were then aggregated for the
entire state of queensland based on the
expected number of multi-drug resistant
isolates arising in queensland hospital
patients given the point prevalence
sequencing data from isolates for the
study came from a two-year research
demonstration
project of prospective whole genome
sequencing for isolates of suspected
outbreaks
the team compared the interventions
whole genome sequencing versus the
standard of care for multi-drug
resistant pathogens
it was thereby assumed
that whole genome sequencing based
surveillance would occur for the six
common multi-drug resistant organisms
for the six most common multi-drug
resistant organisms including
methicillin-resistant staphylococcus
aureus extended spectrum beta-lactamase
producing escherichia coli vancomycin
resistant enterococcus facium
espl producing klebsiella pneumoniae
carbopytamise producing
enterobacterialis and
carbopenem-resistant acinetobacter
bomanii
the study then compared the following
primary and secondary outcomes for both
interventions
expected hospital costs
counts of patient infections and
colonizations
and deaths from bloodstream infections
the authors actually calculated costs
annually across five years from the base
year 2020 on but for simplicity i
highlight the impact of only one year of
whole genome sequencing
the study findings projected that
in 2021 when only relying on standard of
care testing then 97
539 patients in queensland were expected
to be infected or colonized with one of
the six multi-drug resistant organisms
in contrast a whole genome sequencing
based surveillance strategy and earlier
infection control measures
could avoid 36 726 infected or colonized
patients and avoid 650 deaths
these numbers highlighted in green here
on the right hand table deliver a very
clear message about the patient benefit
that can be realized through routine
whole genome sequencing
now let's take a look at the impact on
healthcare costs next
the total cost under the standard of
care
was
170.8 million australian dollars in 2021
whole genome sequencing-based
surveillance
added an additional cost of 26.8 million
australian dollars
this cost however was offset by fewer
costs for cleaning nursing personal
protective equipment shorter hospital
stays and antimicrobials
leading to an overall cost savings of
30.9 million australian dollars in 2021
alone
the authors concluded uh the authors
also conducted a sensitivity analysis
which showed that cost savings remained
even when input values were varied at 95
percent confidence limits
while these studies rely largely on
models rather than being fully
retrospective in nature the models rely
on actual data from outbreaks which have
been managed using whole genome
sequencing needless to say that these
studies have implications for government
resource allocation to health care
they also established a favorable value
proposition for adopting pathogen whole
genome sequencing into the routine
clinical practice
i'd like to conclude this presentation
with a short summary of what we have
discussed
the ground study impressively
established that amr
especially multi-drug resistance in
healthcare-associated infections
is on the rise with fatalities due to
amar growing over 81 globally in only
five years
as discussed also in previous webinars
antibiotic stewardship and the
appropriate use of only effective
antibiotics is a critical requirement to
contain amr
and antibiotic stewardship in turn
depends on next generation diagnostics
for amr surveillance and for infection
prevention and control
whole genome sequencing is a promising
technology proven during the covet 19
pandemic and during countless bacterial
outbreaks
global health organizations urge
healthcare systems to scale up and
coordinate whole genome sequencing in
the clinical routine
we've established today also by
reviewing a number of studies that whole
genome sequencing can be accurate and
reproducible also turnaround times and
costs are quickly becoming conducive to
routine testing in clinics and in low to
mid-income countries
finally a number of studies on the
healthcare economics of routine whole
genome sequencing
of amr pathogens
support the clinical utility both at the
local and the regional level
with that i'd like to invite you to get
in touch if you're interested in whole
genome sequencing and in improving
antibiotic stewardship together
we'd be looking forward to meeting you
either virtually or maybe in person at
the asm microbe in june
of course this webinar series on
combating amr shall continue
expect an invited speaker presenting at
the end of june so stay tuned
a big thank you to all our partners and
collaborators and of course to you for
dialing in today and for your attention
thank you dr materna for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question here says
thank you for this interesting
presentation susceptibility from genomic
data is indeed the next frontier if we
want to see the adoption of ngs in the
clinic beyond surveillance
i assume that the predictive models work
well in pathogens like staph aureus or e
coli for which susceptibility is linked
to the absence of well-characterized
resistance genes
could your ai based approach also help
predict susceptibility for pathogens or
antibiotics with more complex resistance
mechanisms
that's indeed a very good question the
short answer
is yes um common rule-based methods for
the prediction of susceptibility
work well for passage and drug
combinations for which the presence
absence
um
for example of a quiet resistance genes
are the dominant resistance mechanism
the prediction of phenotypic
susceptibility
becomes already much more challenging in
cases for mutations in drug targets or
in regulatory regions for example affect
the amr phenotype
so cases like carbopenemias negative
klebsiella have in fact motivated the
approach that we are using
wherever a number of different genomic
features can either synergistically or
antagonistically interact in their
contribution to the amr phenotype this
is where ai-based predictive models
outperform the simple rule-based models
that rule-based methods sorry as we know
them for example from restfinder and
other tools
great thank you that's the question
that was a wonderful answer thank you we
have another question here this one asks
we would like to sequence isolates to
distinguish between outbreaks in our
hospitals from community acquired cases
the idea is to better inform the action
of the ipc teams but our shared ngs core
cannot always return results fast enough
sometimes we receive first data after
more than one month at which point they
are useful for retrospective outbreak
analysis but not for decision making in
the ipc team
how fast can the aeros genetics lab
return isolate sync with excuse me
sequencing data and can you help us
detect outbreak clusters
yes yes this is indeed a problem we also
hear quite frequently
in the community here in europe
on one hand clinical microbiologists try
to find budgets for isolate sequencing
and on the other hand data arrives so
late that the ipc teams can essentially
no longer act on them
other than maybe publishing a
retrospective outbreak analysis
so to to
to give timely input on whether a sample
falls in fact into an outbreak cluster
or is rather community acquired
we we launched the ares iss express
service so rs iss stands for isolate
sequencing and is a sequencing service
we offer
and this uh the expressed version of
this service uh converts isolates into
clear reports they include foreign for
instance information on genotype but
also clustering and we return
samples uh we turn samples around in as
little as five business days
um
for labs that in fact has in-house ngs
capacity and could therefore accelerate
this further
we have also made
aries cloud which is the software that
our own lab uses for end-to-end data
analysis and reporting
and we've made errors cloud commercially
available as a web application as well
great thank you our next question here
asks our hygiene department is
collecting isolates to monitor the
hospital environment for amr pathogens
we would like to try metagenomic
sequencing but are concerned about
sensitivity especially for amr detection
do you have any advice on this
yeah
that's a good question in in theory deep
metagenomic sequencing can detect any
amr marker in a sample
um but especially for let's say
environmental surveillance think think
of example for example of surface swaps
or sink swabs water samples and so on
the bacterial dna in a sample can be so
sparse and the background of unrelated
dna is so high
that shotgun metagenomic sequencing is
starting to struggle
to achieve good sensitivity and
reproducibility
and
metagenomic surveillance essentially is
a sampling problem so the likelihood of
sampling a pathogen or a mr marker when
sequencing such a sample has to be
shifted in favor of a robust detection
and we are doing this by developing
so-called enrichment methods for
instance
rsupa which stands for universal
pathogen msa
combines on one hand ares id which is
our commercially available amplicon
based approach for the identification of
pathogens with on the other hand a
hybridization capture approach so this
approach enriches
for a panel of over 9 000 among markers
which we have selected from the rsdp
so for
any type of environmental surveillance
in the healthcare environment or
otherwise i would certainly recommend to
use an enrichment based method like
rsid or the rs upa i just mentioned
they're both commercially available
although i have to say that the rsupa is
currently only available as uh
for early access testers but we're
certainly happy to help if
if you have a need there
great thank you
another question here asks how can we
watch the previous webinar series
oh uh the previous webinar series are
available on our website you can find
that under www.opgen.com
aries and uh under the aries brand page
you can find resources which include
links to all the ares webinars but i
think it's probably
best if we just share the link with with
you in in
maybe all the attendees in a follow-up
email as this will also be the place
where you can um watch the webinar on
demand and
and also find a future webinars
great thank you
all right another question here do you
have any idea why mycobacterium
abscesses is not included in leading amr
pathogen even though they are highly
resistant to most of the available
antibiotics
i see so
non-tuberculosis
microbacteria like mycobacterium
abscesses
they certainly
increase more contribute more and more
to healthcare-associated infections but
i think the reason it wasn't included in
the study that the question is referring
to
is probably due to the fact that the
study focused on respiratory tract
infections and as far as i know does uh
mycobacterium abscesses um
rarely contribute to um
to respiratory tract infections um
you it is much more common in soft
tissue infections skin infections and so
on and i believe that might be the
reason why it was not included
fantastic well we are going to go ahead
and wrap up with that final question
there i want to thank you again dr
materna for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank labyrinths and our sponsor opjen
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
you